[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup de mal à imaginer comment
vous allez pouvoir en même temps mener
votre politique est resté fidèle à vos
convictions
vous vous dites gaulliste social mais ne
nous y trompons pas votre gouvernement
penchera bien plus à gauche que vous
malgré vos tentatives peu réussie de
recrutement à droite c'est bien un
programme de gauche que vous allez
devoir appliquer monsieur le premier
ministre pourtant les français n'en
peuvent plus ils attendent un changement
de politique pas un recyclage de
ministre avec quelques têtes d'affiché
alors répondez nous en vérité comme
nouveau capitaine du gouvernement avez
vous le courage de reconnaître que le
cap n'était pas le bon et qu'il est
urgent dans cette vie dans ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
justice
vous ne deviez jamais occupé ce fauteuil
et vous êtes là vous ne deviez jamais
avalé de couleuvres et vous avez retiré
votre plainte pour cette atteinte
inadmissible à votre vie privée et au
secret professionnel
alors monsieur le ministre vos actions
futures seront elles en adéquation avec
vos déclarations passées ou pas monsieur
prémunit ce matin vous avez déclaré
qu'il faut se préparer à une éventuelle
deuxième vague
nous savons que la circulation du virus
en cette période sera démultipliée par
les mouvements saisonniers de population
quelles actions concrètes
avez-vous donc mettre en place pour
éviter une nouvelle flambée de
l'épidémie dans notre pays personne ne
lui la réalité du réchauffement
climatique
il s'impose à nous pas demain
aujourd'hui votre priorité est de
concrétiser les engagements de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
constitue trop souvent un catalogue de
taxes de normes et d'interdictions nous
ne voulons pas d'une écologie punitive
qui opposerait la planète à l'humain
celle qui au fond on veut la
décroissance
monsieur le premier ministre pensez vous
comme nous que la france doit concilier
la croissance et la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
l'écologie est un sujet qui est dans
tous les discours bien pensant
pourtant les décisions prises sur
l'autel sacrificielle de la décroissance
devrait nous questionner notre pays va
connaître la pire crise depuis 1929
dixit
le ministre le maire et vous prenez des
décisions qui coûte cher et dont
l'impact sur la planète sera pire je
vous propose de vous engager sur un
sujet d'actualité sur lequel le
président de la république a lui-même
voulu prendre date l'interdiction du
glyphosate en france ce sujet épineux
provoque un doublé mois dans notre
société
d'un côté l'aspiration des consommateurs
par rapport à l'utilisation de cet
herbicide qui n'est pas appliquée
contrairement aux idées reçues sur des
cultures alimentaires en place et de
l'autre la crainte et les inquiétudes
des agriculteurs français face à
l'absence d'alternative durable et
respectueuse de l'environnement ainsi
que de moyens financiers ce débat n'a
réussi qu'une seule chose
dresser les consommateurs contre les
agriculteurs une annonce étant toujours
plus simple quand elle n'est pas
expliqué l'islam politique trace son
chemin
face à un manque cruel de courage pour y
faire obstacle
et préserver notre unité et les valeurs
de la république
le constat de ces élections municipales
et celui du début malheureusement d'un
morcellement inquiétant que personne ne
peut nier que pour vous la priorité
c'est le vote en urgence et en catimini
de la seconde lecture du projet de loi
de bioéthique et je tiens à insister le
tout en supprimant le vote solennel
initialement prévu on peut et on doit
tout d'abord s'interroger sur
l'opportunité de cette seconde lecture
dans l'hémicycle dans une telle
précipitation et ce site durant la
session extraordinaire
alors que la période estivale débute que
le pays vit sous l'état d'urgence
sanitaire qu'est le conditions ne sont
pas remplies pour un et un débat serein
et apaisé en cette période estivale
il serait pertinent de débattre de cette
question qui en appelle à la team et à
chacun d'entre nous ultérieure je
souhaite vous alerter sur la catastrophe
économique et financière qui risque de
décimer une profession entière
si rien n'est fait en effet seuls les
discothèques font encore à ce jour
l'objet d'une fermeture administrative
contrairement aux cafés restaurants qui
ont pu reprendre leurs activités à
partir du 2 juin sous réserve d'observer
strictement des gestes barrières
à l'échelle du pays ce sont 1600
discothèque et 120 mille emplois directs
qui sont menacés si l'autorisation de
rouvrir ne leur est pas accordée dans
les plus brefs délais vous donnez une
image incontestablement forte de la
justice ce faisant vous créez une énorme
attente
vous avez dressé hier un constat un
constat sans doute sévère mais un
constat que je crois lucide
monsieur le ministre vous allez nous
recevoir et nous nous allons vous
auditionné après la déclaration de
politique générale du premier ministre
nous sommes pressés de vous entendre
nous voulons rentrer dans les détails
dorian nous avions attiré votre
attention sur la situation des écoles
d'enseignement chrétien francophone au
liban alors nous avons eu un début de
réponse cette semaine puisque
l'ambassadeur de france au liban à tout
et un plan de soutien qui s'adresse à 53
établissements mais cinquante trois
établissements c'est loin de toucher
l'ensemble des établissements
francophones
[Musique]